des outils des armes un député combatif
mais avant tout un homme de discussion
et des compromis havrais équilibristes
dit on de lui les qualités recherchées
paraît-il pour être ministre d'autant
que christophe sirugue fait son entrée
au gouvernement en étant pour le moins
difficile
d'être proposée par le président la
république et le premier ministre tient
aussi une forme de responsabilité lourde
dont je mesure ce qu'elle va être en
entrant au gouvernement donc je suis
heureux bien sûr heureux de pouvoir
servir mon pays passée l'émotion le
désormais ex député de saône et loire va
devoir vite se mettre au travail à
seulement huit mois de la présidentielle
lui qui a montré qu'il était un homme de
dossiers avec ses rapports
parlementaires et surtout dans son rôle
de négociateur dans la loi travail très
apprécié par le président de la
république et le premier ministre
appréciez remarquer le voilà donc
récompensé à christophe sirugue
maintenant de défendre l'industrie
française c'est un sujet qui dans une
circonscription comme la mienne que ce
soit le bassin de chalon où le bassin de
la communauté urbaine creusot montceau
me parle beaucoup que ce soit les
questions de reconversion industrielle
les questions de sites industriels je
pense à areva mais il y en a d'autres
bien évidemment donc ce sont les
thématiques que je crois pouvoir à la
fois maîtriser sur lesquels j'ai envie
de travailler donc le fait que ce soit
ce portefeuille la a été déterminant
dans ma décision suite à la proposition
du président de république secrétaire
d'état à l'industrie certes mais
toujours élu local christophe sirugue a
annoncé qu'il restait conseiller
municipal et communautaire de chalon